deux ans après le terrible incendie de
lusine lubrizol la crainte est toujours
là ce dimanche un cortège d'environ 200
personnes à déambuler dans les rues de
rouen pour demander plus de transparence
de la part de l'état sur les risques
sanitaires après le drame du 26
septembre 2019 il ya toujours des zones
d'ombré on réclame l'étude de dangers un
document essentiel que nous avons
utilisée au pénal que nous avons donc
l'exploitation au pénal mais par contre
le procureur refuse de le transit et au
tribunal administratif
là où on va juger justement l'état s'il
a bien fait son travail pourquoi il
refuse pourquoi il répond pas à cette
demande
les manifestants se sont ensuite
rassemblés devant la préfecture où des
animations étaient organisées par des
associations et des partis politiques
ces derniers déplorent qu'aucun
recensement de personnes exposées aux
nuages n'ait été fait selon eux il
aurait permis de traquer sur le long
terme l'apparition ou non de maladie on
n'a pas été alerté on n'était pas
préparés
on cherchait à lever des doutes par
rapport à notre santé donc on voulait
faire des prélèvements par exemple
sanguins des analyses de sang voilà et
toutes ces choses là on s'est constitué
parce qu'on n'y avait pas de réponse
structurée organisée et deux ans après
vous voyez bien on n'a toujours pas eu
d'exercice on n'a pas eu on n'a toujours
pas eu les fameuses moi j'habite rond
depuis deux ans on n'a toujours pas les
plaquettes par exemple les pays qui ont
été distribués dans notre copropriété
sur le quartier neuf de la lucine par
exemple alors que le procès de lusine
n'a toujours pas eu lieu les
associations espèrent également qu'à
l'avenir les industriels agirons en
conséquence faut pas laisser les
industriels pollués notre notre
environnement et les laisser faire sans
réagir il est temps que ces industriels
prennent leurs responsabilités nous si
on en tant que particulier ont fait une
bêtise on est puni tout on est
sanctionné tout de suite et j'aimerais
que ces industriels soient punis aussi
tout de suite
invité au sénat ce mercredi dans le
cadre d'un cycle d'auditions liés à la
catastrophe
les associations de victimes comptent
faire des propositions bien concrètes en
vue de faire bush les choses selon santé
publique france les retombées de suite
de l'incendié de lubrizol et de son
voisin enel logistique concerne près de
215 commune est allé sur cinq
départements soit environ quatre cent
mille habitants